The Internet,
a place with endless possibilities
and all sorts of content
happy memories,
new arrivals,
DIY, lots of food, good and all.
Just adorable.
But in the midst of the joy,
there is also darkness.
Personal information
is rife in the digital world.
And if yours is ever maliciously divulged
without your consent.
Well, that's doxing
doxing derives
from the word docs or documents,
and it comes from the hacking culture
of dropping documents.
It's sharing someone's information online
without their consent
and often
with the malicious intent to attack them.
And undermine them.
That could include, for example,
sharing someone's
home, address
the financial information,
telephone number,
intimate photos, private photos.
To find that information, doctors
might go through search
engines, social media histories,
or data broker websites.
And in some cases they hack.
Once the information is collected,
doctors post the content with the intent
of violating the victim's privacy
and harming them.
And when it comes to targeting women,
the content is often
sexually abusive in nature.
Doxing is more dangerous and egregious
for women than men
because of patriarchal norms.
If you see a topless man,
it's not the same way
of seeing a topless picture of a woman.
They take to a different dimensions
because, you know,
society dictates that this is okay
and this is not okay.
And boxers play on this.
To us,
the effects are also not felt
equally across the world.
A 2020 economist intelligence unit report
showed that
although online
violence against women
is common globally,
at least 90% of respondents
in Latin America and the Caribbean Africa
and the Middle East had been affected
it started in
2019 when
said just the initials of my name.
To say that this kind of women
wants to ruin
our morals wants to ruin our religion.
Karima Nadir is a human rights
advocate in Morocco.
She says she endured
a yearlong defamation campaign
in the form of many online articles
and in tandem.
Karima was also doxed.
In the midst of the lies
true personal information
was published online without her consent.
In 20, 20, it goes to calling me a whore,
a person that speaks with everybody
that had sex for money.
They were like mentioning the city
and the neighbor that I was living in.
And after that,
it went far to even discuss
my right of being a mom that ended up
by publishing
the birth certificate of my son.
So I've decided to change my my home
and to to go and live in another neighbor
when women
are being blocked, often
there is a narrative spin,
a web of disinformation and lies
in order to smear a woman's reputation
and effectively silence her.
I had
many messages on my spam on Facebook,
and at first,
because of the shock,
I started suspecting people around me.
I was just in my room and closing
the door and trying for hours
Doxing takes a cultural dimension.
For example,
a woman's picture
without a veil
can be shared on social media.
And when you look at the photo itself,
it's very benign, is very innocent,
and doesn't really violate
the platform's terms of services.
But looking at the social
and cultural context
in which this doxing is taking
place can be very dangerous and life
threatening to this woman
or somebody posted a photo of me
and somebody else on Twitter
with a caption saying
These are two lesbians
who have started a nonsense
agenda in Ghana.
Take a good look at their faces
in activist
Fatima Darby's case,
the weapon of choice was a photo
as Fatima
shared a picture of her solo
supporting LGBTQ rights in Ghana.
She and the friend
she tagged as the photographer
got attacked.
The docs are combed
through Fatima's
friend's Twitter
and posted a picture of both of them
in a comment.
The attacker invited others
to share their names and addresses
because I was finding in my palms
with sweaty and light, my head
feel hot in my hands.
It's probably because I'm like,
What is this?
What would I do
if somebody's
going to show up at my gigs?
I also felt a lot of guilt because I felt
that I had put somebody else
in a compromising situation
because not random people were people
have not heard of like in years
messaged me saying he asked,
what is false? Is it true?
Are you a lesbian?
You know, that kind of thing.
And it's like,
So if I am a lesbian, does
it mean that I deserve this?
But it was all
but I can sense of helplessness.
Like, I'm reporting to Twitter
not doing anything
The feedback I got
was them
saying that they did
find that
that post
was in violation of any of their laws.
But in giving the context,
giving the increasing violence
that LGBT people in Ghana
would face, and especially at the time,
because that
was extremely dangerous,
extremely violent
Two days later,
Twitter took down the post.
This was after
Fatima contested their decision
and was asked to provide context
as to why the Post should not stay up
for days, including the House
when I had to go outside.
Like I was wearing sunglasses
and in those masks
I had to change my hair
you know,
just do everything to not be recognized.
It created a sense of safety.
You don't know who is watching.
It was a harrowing experience
on social media,
and the
reporting mechanisms
for users
are unfortunately not sufficient.
There is also the question
of jurisdictions
and how each
country might look at the act of doxing,
noting that in many countries,
unfortunately, doxing is not illegal
for adults.
Victim is blamed for being guilty
or responsible.
It's the same thing as blaming
sexual assault victims
of being responsible
of what happens to them.